10 Unforgivable Plot Holes In Marvel Movies
As entertaining as comic book movies are,
one thing they have classically lacked over
the years is airtight storytelling.
The action is usually exciting, the special
effects are often state-of-the-art, and the
visuals are usually a colourful aesthetic
treat – but all of that becomes moot if
the plot sucks.
The Marvel Cinematic Universe has attempted
to buck the trend of poor plots in the genre.
Movies like Iron Man, Captain America: The
Winter Soldier and Guardians of the Galaxy
were great productions by any standards – but
that doesn’t mean the franchise hasn’t
suffered from some glaring plot holes.
For clarity, plot holes are logical inconsistencies
within a story.
They can include things like inexplicable
or impossible events occurring, or events
that contradict earlier events in the storyline
– and you might be surprised at just how
many there have been in the MCU.
Here are 10 unforgivable plot holes in Marvel
movies.
Captain America Vs The Red Skull
In 2011’s Captain America: The First Avenger,
there’s a sequence of events that results
in an outcome that was frankly incredibly
implausible.
Cap storms Red Skull’s HYDRA base alone
and ends up getting captured.
He’s taken to a room in the base where he
meets the Nazi supervillain, and Cap’s friends
happen to burst through the window to save
him.
This scenario relied on way too many assumptions.
How did Cap know he’d be captured and not
killed?
That base was huge - how did he know the room
he’d be taken to would be the one his friends
were going to burst into?
How did he know the glass they smashed in
order to enter wasn’t bulletproof?
It’s all far too convenient to be taken
seriously.
The Bifrost Problem
In 2011’s Thor movie, it was Loki’s plan
to open the Bifrost – the bridge connecting
Asgard to the rest of the Nine Realms around
the universe – and use its energies to destroy
the realm of Jotunheim to prove himself worthy
of ruling Asgard to Odin.
In order to prevent him from doing that, Thor
destroyed the Bifrost, which resulted in him
being trapped on Asgard away from Jane Foster
– his Earth-based lover.
Thor was devastated as a result, and yet in
2012’s The Avengers he arrived on Earth
as soon as he felt he was needed there, with
a half-baked explanation about Odin using
dark energy to send him back.
If it was that easy, why was he so devastated
in the first place?
And why didn’t he just ask Odin to send
him back to Jane earlier?
Everyone Knows Where Everyone Else Is Going
In 2012’s The Avengers, everyone seemed
to have an uncanny knack of “just knowing”
where other individuals were heading, simply
because it suited the plot – but it really
made no sense.
For instance, Tony Stark assumed that Loki
wanted to be seen by the masses conquering
Earth – describing him as wanting a monument
with his name plastered on it – and he immediately
knew that meant he’d set up camp at Stark
Tower.
How?!
There are literally thousands of buildings
on planet Earth that would have provided Loki
with what he needed.
Moreover, how the heck did Bruce Banner know
EXACTLY where to find his fellow Avengers
in the HUGE city of New York?
Seriously, this kind of thing was far too
prevalent in The Avengers.
Bruce Banner’s Anger
The degree over which Bruce Banner has control
over his anger and his transformations into
the Hulk is something that really needs to
be clarified.
In 2012’s The Avengers, the trauma caused
by an attack on the S.H.I.E.L.D.
Helicarrier triggered an involuntary transformation,
but Banner later proclaimed that he was “always
angry” and therefore had total control over
his transformations.
Then, in 2015’s Avengers: Age of Ultron,
the Scarlet Witch was able to trigger an involuntary
transformation that even made the Hulk get
into a fight with his good friend Tony Stark
AKA Iron Man.
Granted, this transformation was triggered
by the mysterious powers of the aforementioned
Maximoff twin, but it still suggests that
Banner isn’t quite as in control of his
body as a major plot point in The Avengers
would have us believe.
The Fall of the Chitauri
At the end of 2012's The Avengers, Iron Man
single-handly defeats the invading Chitauri
army by diverting a nuclear missile towards
their mothership.
Every last one of them drops down dead when
the ship is destroyed.
How?
Prior to the nuking, there was absolutely
no evidence of the Chitauri operating under
a hive mind and they weren't cybernetic beings,
so there's no reason that the destruction
of a ship should have resulted in their deaths.
It just seemed like far too convenient a method
of ensuring they were all accounted for.
Tony Stark and Extremis
2013's Iron Man 3 ended with Tony Stark having
learned everything there was to know about
Aldrich Killian's Extremis formula.
As a result, he not only stabilised it in
order to cure Pepper Potts of its effects,
he also used it to enable surgeons to remove
shrapnel and the arc reactor from his chest
without killing him.
And yet he hasn't used it since.
Why?
A stabilised Extremis could be used to save
lives and regrow limbs.
Stark had the intelligence to make it into
an extremely useful applied tool, but he decided
to bury it in the archives?
That's far too hard to believe - especially
given that Stark and his friends are in the
dangerous business of superheroics.
Everlasting 80s Technology
It’s not a stretch to call Star-Lord’s
Walkman a major plot point in 2014’s Guardians
of the Galaxy.
It’s extremely important to the heroic outlaw.
It keeps him going and is his only real remaining
connection to his late mother and his home
planet of Earth – but how the hell is it
still working?
Chris Pratt’s character left Earth 26 years
prior to the events of the movie and, unless
there are AA batteries in space, that Walkman
should have died long ago – and that’s
without even mentioning the general wear and
tear on both the device itself and the tape
inside it, as well as the fact that Star-Lord
often finds himself in the kind of dangerous
situations that would see it taking a regular
beating.
English: The Universal Language
It isn't only the Marvel Cinematic Universe
in which this inexplicably happens, but it's
still something that should bug you.
Planet Earth alone consists of around 6,500
spoken languages - and yet we're expected
to believe that the majority of the rest of
the universe conveniently speaks perfect English?
2014's Guardians of the Galaxy revealed that
Xandarians, Kree, Zehoberei, Centaurians,
Luphomoids, Krylorians, space racoons, and
even the Mad Titan Thanos are just some of
the beings in the MCU that are fluent English
speakers.
How is that remotely possible?
Avengers Assemble!
(But only when it suits them)
Ever since the assembling of the Avengers
in their 2012 movie, questions have been asked
about why any of the team's individual members
have had to deal with villain problems on
their own.
Iron Man, Thor and Captain America have all
had their issues - with Aldrich Killian and
his Extremis army, Malekith and the Dark Elves,
and the Winter Soldier and HYDRA respectively
- so why didn't their heroic teammates offer
some assistance?
In a world where the Avengers (and even S.H.I.E.L.D.)
make it their business to turn up wherever
there's major trouble brewing, it's hard to
believe that Thor had to deal with what was
essentially another alien invasion on his
own, or that the three Helicarriers that were
targeting thousands of people considered to
be threats to HYDRA were only opposed by Captain
America.
Captain America’s Shield
Captain America’s shield is awesome – of
that there is no doubt.
But it’s also one gigantic plot hole.
It seems to pick and choose when it works
depending on the situation.
For instance, it will easily absorb the impact
of the mighty Thor’s Mjolnir and will deflect
Tesseract-powered energy weapons effortlessly,
but when the Winter Soldier throws a grenade
and Cap holds up his shield to absorb the
impact, he gets brutally launched from an
interstate to the underpass below.
And when Cap uses it as a projectile, it also
seems to pick and choose what it will bounce
off and what it will wedge itself into.
And let’s not get into the fact that it
blocks every single bullet or projectile fired
at Cap, even when 90% of his body is totally
exposed.
Thanks for watching our list of 10 unforgivable
plot holes in Marvel movies.
Did these plot holes bug you?
Did we leave any major examples out?
Let us know in the comments section below
and be sure to subscribe to our channel for
more great videos like this one!